hey Milo Ventimiglia here at BuzzFeed
today gonna be hanging out with puppies
my life sucks and answering some
questions that you guys may have about
the art of racing in the rain or
anything else okay so as you can see
I've got puppies so let's answer some
questions what do you think about answer
a question what is your favorite memory
from working with Amanda Seyfried on the
art of racing in the rain I got a lot of
memories about working with Amanda she
is fun she's fiercely talented I was so
grateful to have her as my partner hey
my wife
there's no cookies in there delivering
cookies there's no cookie you got
puppies but no cookie he's out of here
she's out of here you think you'll ever
want a golden retriever now that you've
gotten to work and bond with Parker in
the art of racing the rain
I want Parker there was a guarantee hike
there was a guarantee that any pup any
of these pups could be just like Parker
well then I'd love to have a Parker yeah
see come on you want to read that one
what does that say who do you think you
have more in common with Jess or Jack
Jack I think it's just age right now
Jess liked to read but Jack Jack and I
these days you got a lot more in common
like love this is actually pretty
distracting oh oh okay back to a
question what's a role that people would
be surprised to find out you auditioned
for I auditioned in an open cattle call
to play Robin in Batman and Robin when I
was 16 years old at Warner Brothers and
there were thousands of people there
they just kind of eyeballed people
looked at people and decided if they
wanted to see them more and they didn't
they just wanted to see Chris O'Donnell
in reference to heroes if you could
choose one superhuman ability what would
you choose teleportation that's been my
con yeah me too
teleportation has always been my
constant cuz like you could be here at
the puppies or you could like go to
maybe your own couch hi you got big paws
freaking big
or you could go like home and hang out
with your own pooch if you were so
inclined which of any of your cast mates
from any project you've worked on would
you choose to go on a backpacking
adventure with I'm gonna say Mandy Moore
because she likes to go up mountains she
kind of knows what she's doing with
regards to that right now
so I'm gonna save me anymore let him go
up a mountain with me anymore I'm gonna
try this one that's a bad one
do you still hang out with any of your
Gilmore Girls co-stars no I haven't seen
them in a long time but I do still talk
to Dan and Amy Amy sherman-palladino and
Dan Palladino who created the show wrote
the show and did everything on the show
give me a question okay I'll get you
that which of Jack Pearson's styles of
facial hair is your favorite usually
it's the mustache because that's the
constant but we go back in the past a
lot these days so yeah I'm kind of
getting used to just being clean-shaven
for a little while
which is not too bad oh is that the spot
I'm from the spot oh there's the spot
looks like I got an audience of one now
come on up come on
what is one movie that you would always
enjoy watching one movie Goonies
everybody in the room is collectively
knotted cuz yes Goonies but what's your
favorite comfort food burritos bean and
cheese they're everything it's a little
burrito right here little nugget brutal
would you rather eat no food on
Thanksgiving or no candy and Halloween
I'd say no candy on Halloween like you
get older candy just kind of like you
know affects you makes you stay up late
I'm cool without the sugar come on guys
which question should I do the right
hand to the left hand somebody sniff one
I guess neither of those questions are
getting read that's just not gonna
happen today what would be your perfect
day off can we just appreciate this
moment right here how about a perfect
day on it's a perfect day on what TV
show from your past you wish you could
have done one more season of mob City
mob city whole cast of
amazing actors Jeremy Luke I think that
would been an interesting season - have
you ever kept or borrowed something from
the this is us set no just kind of it
all stays there stays on set so we could
come back and revisit and use it later
you guys want keys what's your favorite
Jess and Rory moment from Gilmore Girls
I can tell you it's actually from the
episode called teach me tonight it's
when they're driving around getting ice
cream and cones and calling that was a
fun episode of film flex it's not a good
time what's the worst pick-up line
you've ever heard any pickup line is a
bad pick-up line guys girls everyone
just walk up and introduce yourself say
hi I'm so-and-so and that's it and
that's it no pickup lines
right Milo I'm a fellow alumni of
al-madinah and I'm curious if you still
keep in touch with mrs. Herto from the
drama department
she was the absolute best I do from time
to time catch up with my high school
drama teacher she's amazing she's one of
the ones to thank I think for me being
in front of the camera and acting
because without her encouragement I
might have gone a different path I might
have done something else so thank you
mrs. Harry what have you learned most
from playing Jack Pearson I don't know
what I've learned most from playing Jack
Pearson but I think the thing that I
love the most is Jack's love of his
family okay last one who do you think
Rory should have ended up with Dean Jess
or Logan none of the above
they're from the past people were
already needs to move on forever in life
okay hey guys thank you so much all of
these puppies all these beautiful
beautiful beautiful puppies that you see
with me here today
are available for adoption at North
Shore Animal League America they can be
kissing your neck just like that it's
really
it's months go see art of racing in the
rain it opens August 9th I know he's
excited she's excited I hope you guys
are excited to go to the movie opens
this weekend
[Music]